I'll turn my camera on my fingers early
last year I actually started looking at
all of the open-source ecosystems that
we have any kind of data on and by
ecosystem I mean people that are
publishing packages in that language
that other people can use and so you can
get some data from github but the really
good data actually just comes out of the
package managers and what I started
doing was asking certain questions of
this data then nobody was really asking
and people are making a lot of
assumptions about the most important one
being you know is is growth somewhat
stable and predictable can we actually
predict that growth and then if it is
predictable than what does that actually
tell us about how the source ecosystems
grow one thing that I did that actually
worked really well was rather than start
charting the absolute number of packages
and focusing on that I charted growth as
a percentage of the ecosystem as a whole
so you know if you had a thousand
packages and you added 100 you would
have ten percent growth and if you had
10,000 packages and you added 100 you
would have one percent growth and then
the next quarter the next time that you
measure the growth it's going to be you
know what that much harder to reach that
growth again and so what you would
expect is that all of the ecosystems
with those numbers would be coming down
right it's getting harder and harder to
grow at that rate and certainly some
open source ecosystems are dying
certainly some of them people are you
know not really that into you know like
come on like nobody writes Haskell that
Haskell is like dying right and but
actually what I found was was pretty
startling it turns out that no
open-source ecosystem is dying it turns
out that all of them are actually
growing at a pretty sustainable raid I
mean they do fall a little bit but over
a couple years you're looking at a half
to two percent right but some are
growing dramatically more than others
and that led me to disprove to like
really important assumptions that we've
been making for a long time
one was that you know these numbers were
unpredictable you know they are they're
actually very predictable this this
graph I took that those numbers those uh
basically the average growth per quarter
and I'm striking it out for the next
three years at the time so this goes to
the end of next year and Isaac texted me
the other day and told me that last
month we we went over a hundred thousand
packages and node last month and this
predicts it about down to the day and
this was made in April this graph has
made in april of last year so about a
year and a half afterwards it's holding
very very true so if it continues to
hold true for about a year we're going
to be you know close to 300,000 packages
we're going to be double the size of
Ruby that's that's pretty tremendous but
the other more important assumption that
this totally destroyed was that um oh
the growth of one ecosystem is at the
expense of another that when note grows
it's because people are ditching Python
and they're ditching Ruby and you know
there or you know when go is growing
it's because people are jumping ship
from node because you know TJ wrote a
blog post and this is actually not true
it turns out that open source ecosystem
growth almost entirely comes from what
you could call non-consumption right so
that's non consumption in terms of
people that are writing code and not
publishing open source packages so if
you make it easier and you have a
culture of participation where people
want to publish and they're incentivize
to publish then they will so you get a
lot of growth out of that and then you
also get a lot of growth out of what you
could call a mature ization so taking a
task that used to be only accessible to
a couple really smart programmers that
knew how like [ __ ] b-trees worked and
stuff and then you make it super simple
and easy for almost anybody to use
including you know high school dropouts
and then you know they make awesome
websites with it and really creative
stuff that people who know how b-trees
work could never do and and so like
that's that's really important because
if you're trying to grow an ecosystem
you need to learn these lessons about
how things actually grow so I was paying
attention to this graph for a long time
containing attention to the massive
growth of node you know now we are by
far the largest ecosystem
in the world we're still the fastest
growing ecosystem in the world although
packages being bringing PHP up there so
PHP is having another growth spurt again
no mumbles it's still okay I think stuff
all right but what I wasn't paying
attention to with until recently was
this graph this is the contributions to
node core graph and it is decidedly not
growing you know you can see that over
the last couple years we've had sort of
a smaller decline and then last year a
pretty huge decline in the last looks
like two or three months we're getting
pretty close to zero and considering
that we have the largest ecosystem in
the world we have you know we're the
fastest growing use in the world there
are a lot of incentives for people to
want to contribute to node and they're
not there they are decidedly not
contributing to it and this is this is
about the problem but also you know like
why you know we have this great project
people are clearly using it why aren't
people could have been decorum another
more concerning even more concerning
graph is this one this is the number of
stable releases per year of node so you
can see that even all the way through
2013 we're doing a lot of stable
releases I mean this includes patch
releases right so bug fixes and security
fixes and that kind of stuff and then
this year we have just this huge decline
I mean there's a month left of this year
but it's not going up much and you know
we we had two huge security problems
this year right like two huge security
like SSL fixes that had to go out so
that's you know two of these seven or
eight releases so we're also not
releasing so the code that is getting in
we're not getting it out the door people
are starting to kind of wonder like what
the hell is going on with this project
and you know if I were to show you the
NPM update graph which is the number of
updates to packages so not just new
publishes like we saw in the previous
graph but also people continuing to
maintain an update packages it actually
see that that growth that graph grows
even faster than the number of packages
like new packages published so you know
updates to things and continuing stable
releases inside of the eCos
is growing tremendously and then it's
not happening in code core so if we want
to fix this we have to figure out what
works what is working in the ecosystem
that we're all participating in that's
growing like crazy that now has you know
100,000 modules and what parts of that
are not true for core and let's make
them true for it so that we can
potentially fix this so this is a
visualization a simple simplified
visualization of the level up ecosystem
and there's a lot of other ecosystems
inside of NPM that look a lot like this
right you could look at some of the
stuff to McCullough sheng co does with
ndarray and it would look a lot like
this as well where you have sort of
layers of different modules that
accomplish different tasks and then they
sort of have these different dependency
chains on top of them and in a lot of
cases actually there is this sort of
linchpin module the module that sort of
like is at the center of this little
ecosystem and when you when you really
break down npm where you find are lots
of different clusters of things and
sometimes they're around something like
level up but sometimes they're just
around a person right like you know some
stack and dominic tar and max ogden like
they they have a bunch of modules that
they use together in certain ways really
often and they form this little sort of
ecosystem but there's a few things you
need to know about this right like one
is that all of these independent modules
are run by different people there's a
certain amount of ownership that goes
along with these smaller kind of single
maintainer modules and they they're
basically able to operate completely
independent of each other so nobody's
anybody's boss nobody owns anybody else
and the only time that that isn't really
the case is in this level up module
right level up actually is in a similar
position to what you can call a node
core is right like a lot of people
depend on it on both sides of the stack
and so it should exhibit a lot of the
same problems the core does but it
actually doesn't so this is a really
good thing to look at and to try and
figure out you know ways that we might
improve note in the future so this is
rod bag rod is the creator of level up
and is still one of the the prime
maintain errs a really great guy great
addition to the note community you'll
see his name pop up a lot the more that
you get into things but Rob decided to
run the project very very differently
than we've seen a lot of open source
project from before any key came up with
this new system that he called open open
source I don't think that the acronym
actually means anything he just
capitalizes it to reinforce the fact
that his [ __ ] open open source open
up this is the first line of the
contributing file for for it and that
this is the description of open open
source which is that at individuals
making significant and valuable
contributions are given commit access to
the project to contribute as they see
fit this project is more like an open
wiki than a standard guarded open source
project so it turns out that get is like
really good at removing mistakes you
can't screw up get the way that you can
screw up like a subversion repository
and a lot of these crazy kind of
safeguards and hierarchies that we have
around giving people commit access
they're really not that warranted
anymore when we can revert things so
simply and easily right like we may want
to guard the keys to doing releases and
pushing releases to NPM but in terms of
like actually guarding commit access
that's not all that necessary and so he
sort of figured this out he added this
to the project he started just giving
commitment to anybody that sent a patch
that was more than four or five lines
long and what ended up happening was a
lot of people including me dominic tar
and Palo Fragomeni and all of the people
that sort of depend on level up on every
side of this ecosystem they all got
commit access and they all had a shared
sense of responsibility for the project
and it's it's easy to con somebody into
having a shared sense of responsibility
for some time you know you can say like
oh you know I really believe in you
write this stuff and then but if you
don't give them ownership over it if you
don't like if you don't treat the if you
don't act as a participant yourself if
you don't come with a pull request just
like everybody else and you sort of
continue to act like a dictator people
start to understand that they actually
don't have any ownership over this and
their participation will go down a lot
and their sense of responsibility over
the project will go down quite a bit and
and for the people that don't do that
they'll just burn themselves out I mean
look though they'll get so care mad
about everything that happens and
they'll sort of flip out and it's all
because they they feel a lack of control
over their own work and this model that
rod came up with has been hugely
successful in avoiding all these
pitfalls you know there's a heap there's
an amazing active and engaged community
that shares ownership over the project
and it's it maintained very very
responsibly without you know all these
crazy safeguards that we sort of obsess
over okay so um can talk a little bit
about notes cool so a lot of people have
been doing notes cool we there was one
here people talked about new schools lot
notes cool it really sort of came out of
out of the out of the note conferences
so note comp 2012 sub stack wrote this
little stream adventure workshop room in
fact we heard for that year I decided
that note comp was just going to be all
hands on and so most people just
collaborated on building slides in a
whole curriculum and sub-sect tried to
do that for about five minutes before he
flipped out and was like screw this no
and like and then he's like I'm just
going to run a module and so he writes
this module that's you know an
interactive workshop that was by far the
best workshop that year everybody really
loved it to moxley love the rod bag
loved it so much that when he went to to
moxies conference camp j/s a few months
later he he rewrote all of his workshop
materials in a very similar format so
that you could have this sort of
interactive presentation style and then
a few months later at node comfy you
there's you know five of these
interactive workshops and we put them
all under this banner and call it note
school and it really took off from there
and then shortly after that i created
this issue and this is like my favorite
github issue in the history of open
source it's so great so like I just sort
of put together resources for people
running localized node schools in their
town or whatever
and I said you know hey run one you know
when you're done like totally come back
and tell us all about it and so and this
thread just blew up for months so tons
of people were running these they were
coming back and saying what worked and
what didn't work we were all inter ating
on how we did them and you know people
started sending in all these awesome
photos and attaching them to the issue
as well so you know these are from and
these are from all over the world I mean
you know you got London and China and
Australia I think there's a little bit
of San Francisco in there Columbia like
they've met een Columbia's in there and
this is all happening within like the
first few months and we were so excited
that we we kind of didn't notice when
growth kind of plateaued like we had a
bunch of new people come and run them
and then we we basically exhausted I
guess the number of people that could
just figure this out from that issue and
it stagnated for a little while and then
you know max Ogden who you may have seen
earlier he decided that he was going to
sort of like take on some more
leadership and organize things a bit and
what he did was one he just documented
very very well how to run a note school
you know you don't need it any money you
don't need to pay for pizza and beer
unless you want to like just you know
it's very very simple you know here are
these materials that's it but then he he
found a way to adopt to adapt rod begs
open open source to this like new
growing community of note schools
because one of the problems that you
have in distributing this project is
like well how do you share ownership
over something that is literally global
and people are running them in their
local acts in their local community so
you created this note school github org
and basically anybody who comes along
and says I want to run a new node school
they get added as an owner of the entire
org and then from there they create a
repo for their local node school chapter
which you know means that they get a
website and and also that github repo
ends up being an issue tracker for them
to organize the event and for anybody
that was at the event to follow up later
and then then he did something just
[ __ ] genius he he told them that at
the end of every node school they should
get the github handles of everybody who
attended
and add them as an owner of the
individual repository so now they're all
watching the repo they're all following
up and it makes this line between I just
learn node I know a little bit more
about node now I'm helping out to run a
node school now I'm entering it makes
that continuum and that transition so
simple and easy and it ended again it
shares ownership of the localized event
which means that people have a shared
sense of responsibility for keeping it
running it's really genius there's
worked incredibly well and now we're i'm
on the owners thread so I know about
every single one that comes in and it's
like two or three a week or being added
it's crazy and then you know I have to
unsubscribe from this repo because it's
like all in Japanese and and and and
just recently you know Max's been on a
kick of trying to get everybody to
translate as well so there's a ton of
translations for the node school website
trying to translate all the work
shoppers there's a new concerted effort
to try and distribute ownership of that
as well it's going really really well
another thing max put together in in
Oakland the the hometown of node is
Oakland Jas so the reason I bring this
up is that you know there's everybody's
been to a meetup probably meet it's very
common Oakland Jace is just a little bit
different it's not a thing where people
go and talk or pitch there's no speak
there's no speakers at all we we have it
at the sort of the outdoor beer garden
and it's just a place for people to come
and relax and sort of continued to build
a community over a long period of time
and the secret to its success is that we
do it every week and so nobody is there
every time nobody is even in charge of
making it happen it just happens every
week and people just show up every week
and you don't have to feel weird about
not showing up or showing up again but
one thing that this is started to do is
that for the first time we're attracting
a lot of non-programmers into
programming into this local community um
because one thing that we we found out
through the note schools is that people
if people can reach out to someone that
they've met they're far more likely to
follow up if they're really new to
programming there's certain things that
are just terrifying to ask online
in fact one thing that the local node
school chapter started doing that I've
been stealing really liberally is that
they started creating get er chat rooms
for their local node school and at first
I was like why like if people want help
they should just go to like a main node
school one but no it's actually done
really well because people who will go
to these local event they'll have a
question and they'll just be terrified
to ask it if anybody except the people
that they just met at that meet up and
so having sort of like you know weekly
informals and having you know these
localized support systems really help us
bring in what will eventually be the
next generation of new programmers write
like these are these are possibly people
that aren't going to be full-time
programmers you know they're going to
work instead of government and they need
to process some data and they want to
know how to do that in a way that works
on the web or you know they work in
education and so they have an interest
in this and it's going to help them do
their job but you know they're not going
to work at a [ __ ] startup and that's
great because we don't need more
startups but we need or more where
people writing useful [ __ ] so but uh
yeah so like these these are all just
great day and like here's a couple more
photos from from our local Oakland Jas
and you know literally like we don't
even have the same table each week
because we don't have a reserve space so
people just have to kind of look around
and try to figure out like where laptops
are and then it's like oh hey you are
and I started bringing like those little
bits and now we're playing with those
all the time but it's just been really
fun and we noticed people coming back
week after week that just would never
come to a meet up and we're really
pulling them into this into this
community and we never would have been
able to get them any other way so I
highly suggest doing something like this
but ok so the future right this is
future town so what what is the future
of node look like that's what the talk
is supposed to be about so I better
bring back around so the future of note
is it's actually you in that you know
node is a participatory culture
everything that we've succeeded at we've
succeeded at because we have a brita
saboteur II culture and because we've
been amateur izing these these tasks and
now we have to move on to the next phase
of that which means like all of
you need to participate and all of you
need to to get involved in ways that you
know we have some examples of before but
you know we need to find new ways to
collaborate in new ways to get involved
so the first izle is you know local like
if you don't have a community in your
town you can build one if you do have a
little one you can grow it you can make
it more cohesive and it's really not
that hard and there's now a lot more
resources so you can run a note school
there's incredibly detailed information
on how to run a note school I mean
literally you know dozens of people are
running them every month you know all of
the workshop or materials are there for
you to use it's it's a really and it's a
really great experience to be a mentor
and to teach people things you'll
actually learn a lot by teaching other
people if you if you if you know you
have a bit more of a community you want
to bring in some you know out of town
speakers and really get people in your
city or town excited about about note
and about JavaScript I started doing
this thing called node cough one shot
and I liberally stole from what max did
with notes cool and essentially
documented how to run a very simple very
stripped down one day conference it
doesn't cost a lot of money it's not
that hard there's instructions on there
on how to do a really great CFP and how
to select good talks like you know
really anybody can run these we were
going to do four of them this year
there's you know already two on the
books for next year so really if if you
feel like you want to step it up another
notch check out one shot okay and then
there's no forward which everybody's
probably been waiting for me to talk
about so so note forward it's to get up
work that I created and a campaign that
a lot of people are now involved in
where we're really just trying to get no
decor back on track and not just knowed
core but we're trying to solve a lot of
the problems inside of the note
community and ecosystems that aren't
solvable with just one module right they
do require the collaboration of more
people inside of the ecosystem and so
some some great examples of this are
onboarding so new people come to
JavaScript and no
and they land at API Docs and you can't
learn [ __ ] if you don't know anything
about note already it just by looking at
API Docs and there are a lot of great
resources that people have built for for
learning JavaScript and for learning
note I mean max Ogden wrote this amazing
one called jazz for cats that is
literally you know a cat's guide to
learning JavaScript it's adorable and
you know there's you know a node.js
handbook and there's all these great
resources there's even knowed school but
finding them and seeing them laid out in
a cohesive way that says you know I
would want to go and do this really
isn't there so Tracy Abrams and a bunch
of other people are leading this really
great effort to sort of consolidate some
of this material and build a website
that is basically a landing page for new
node users that we can start pointing
people at and you know if you're into
documentation you're into usability you
know how to make pretty websites like
you can help out with this so just go to
this repo and pitch in the next is help
so I don't know if you've ever been on
the node.js mailing list but is it's a
cesspool it's just it's the worst don't
go there just don't unless you want to
know a lot about fibers it's so but and
but people like legitimately show up
with real questions and they're like
help me and then they'll learn about
fibers instead and so we've been trying
to fix this for a long time I mean for
snowmobiles done a great job of
moderating the mailing list but it's
still just not like a super accessible
thing so we created a github repo and
we're using the issue track you tracker
there for people to ask questions and
help but we also actually have a git er
room because we vet we've found that get
er just being on the web and being
simple we're getting people that won't
pop into IRC very simply very easily so
if you want to help people you know you
can you can watch this repo to provide
help for people you can pop into that
Gator channel and help any new users out
we're already getting a pretty good
amount of people come popping in and
forest is sort of leading that project
along with some other people next one is
one that I'm getting pretty excited
about because we've been talking about
it forever but it's
always kind of stalled out and I got
anywhere but now it's really happening
which is basically a sort of like global
open-source mentorship program so
essentially the idea is that you know a
mentor signs up and says you know I know
about this kind of stuff I can dedicate
about these many hours a week to helping
out a new person and then they get on
you know Google hangout or a skype or
whatever with new people that come along
that want to learn more and one we sort
of like build a lot better relationships
with newer people and pull them into the
community like really deeply and also
it's just a good educational effort so
right now you can go to that repo and
then the readme has a list of mentors
and if you're up for mentoring then just
send a pull request and add yourself and
that's a great way that you can help out
then there's some core stuff so we have
we have a discussions repo for any other
problems that I haven't talked about or
any new issues there's already some
threads there that are there barring
some fruit one is the the first one that
I added to the repo which is called all
the maths but essentially I don't know
if you know this but are and sigh pie
and all of these like crazy math
libraries that I had mex talk about
they're basically just fortran code it's
just fortran code that they bind to and
these four trim libraries are fine
ancient and i was like hey can we cross
compile this like can we do something
how do we fix this and so we had a long
discussion about it and just recently
because nobody could get em script in
with fortran support to install like sup
one person he made a docker image for it
so now anybody can run this docker image
and he actually cross compiled all of
these ancient for like a la pack the
this fortran mega library with M
scripting and and yeah so any other
problems that you think you know the
noted community needs to address you
should bring up there it's also a really
nice repo to just watch and participate
in another one which is also being run
by rod bag is build so the the current
build system for core is I think it
might just be down or it's just not
running or whatever but it's really not
that reliable so one we want like a
better automated build system for core
that runs all the tests we want to get
like you know
formas tests running we want to also
when for every build of core we should
really be running like the npm tests and
we should really be running like the
tests of the most popular modules out
there so we know that we're not breaking
something on top of node not just note
itself and so and another thing is that
we want it to be really robust right
like right right now it's all on like
one providers infrastructure and that's
just not going to hold up so like almost
a dozen companies now have like given
resources to this you know I gave some
digital ocean but you know voxer went
and bought like Mac minis and put them
in a data center for Mac testing you
know we're getting like freebsd stuff in
there IBM and soft layer through and
some resources so we're getting a lot of
people into this right now it's um what
is that awful Java thing some awful Java
Sea I but rod can't use anything in Java
for long too long before he regrets it
and node so there's there's also an
up-and-coming CI utility written a node
that will be probably switching to at
some point so you can go to that repo
and pitch in if you're like a build
person the roadmap so it's been a
complaint for as long as I've been
working on node stuff that core is a
very homogeneous group of people and
this because like you know to work on
core most of the people especially the
people that came early on came from kind
of server backgrounds and formerly
low-level backgrounds and if you look at
the growth like more than half of no
juice issues in front and tooling and so
getting that feedback into the core
group has been very difficult and it's
been locked up in a lot of weird process
so we have this roadmap repo where we're
sort of like asking questions and coming
up with more creative ways of getting
feedback from people so we can try to
figure out what are the biggest issues
that did people need addressed in core
so we can feed that into an eventual
roadmap right but the the purpose of the
project now and there's a couple threads
on there you can participate in which is
about figuring out what the biggest pain
points are in node from every different
part of the community so we can get all
that consolidated and the last one which
is not actually on node forward but it's
very important it's called man worst
name ever rod but so if you use any like
see live
every major release of node they break
because v8 dramatically changes its API
during every release and so what we're
trying to do with nan does basically it
provides like enough surface area for
most people to bind to that are doing
like a native extension or a sea
extension and it straddles the different
versions of v8 that are in major
releases of node and it's sort of like
you know constantly getting like
refactored and and there's a lot of work
going into it right now but what we're
hoping is that this kind of eventually
become the unofficial sort of blessed
way for you to do native add-ons if you
can there's always going to be a section
of the native like parts of native add
on that you may need to bind directly to
v8 but the more that you can use this
the less pain that you'll go through
during every major release of node and
the less pain that you know everybody
who uses your module will go through so
that's sort of the summary of the the
current work that's me I'm Michael
Rogers and when I'm not running node
events I'm the director of evangelism a
digital ocean thank you
you